The three step assertive technique is used to firmly but courteously put your point of view.
It involves making three statements...
...using a calm and even voice while retaining an upright, relaxed posture.
First, you summarize the other person's point of view...
...then express yourself by saying what you think or feel.
Finally, you suggest an action.
It often helps to use the following phrases as a memory aid.
I understand you think...
However, I feel...
Therefore, I suggest...
I'm not sure that I can achieve this goal.
I understand that you think the objective is too challenging.
However, I do feel it's just the type of target you've achieved in the past.
Therefore, I suggest to draw up a project plan...
...based on how you meet this goal and we can review together next week.